okay so I can't think of a film that has
had this much hype in all honesty this
movie premiered at festivals in 2011
I've been hearing how good this movie is
since 2011 now is that much hype gonna
ruin this movie or is it gonna make it
even better
[Music]
you're next is a new home invasion
thriller and anymore with home invasion
thrillers you have to do something
different because there's so many of
them now they have to do some new twists
or some new look at the genre to make it
different or appealing to an audience I
mean this year already we've had the
purge and they tried to add this whole
it's legal tonight vibe to it and which
made it different than others your next
shows us this family and their friends
coming together at this big beautiful
house for this meal and lo and behold
three guys in animal masks decide you
know what we're gonna break into this
house and we're gonna screw things up
for them we've seen it all before right
sort of see for me the third act of your
next was fantastic it really switched
gears it changed up the entire film
completely and it really started the
tribute retro 80s horror right down to
the symphonic music it was awesome
unfortunately the first two acts in the
movie felt pretty much run-of-the-mill
for me there were jokes that were trying
to be made to kind of insert dark comedy
into the movie and sometimes it works
and sometimes it made for awkward laughs
in the audience where they weren't
entirely sure are we supposed to laugh
at this or is this supposed to be
serious for a few different characters
some of the acting is truly appalling
and I couldn't get over it for a large
portion of the movie and I definitely
saw the ending coming it was very
in-your-face that the certain thing was
going to happen and of course it did it
wasn't really that surprising it was
pretty predictable the first two acts of
the movie just were very run-of-the-mill
straightforward home invasion there's
guys outside they're gonna break in
they're gonna kill people in various
ways it's when the third act started one
one particular character this awesome
badass chick who kind of rose suddenly
as the lead of the character very much
in the vein of the film alien will you
show an entire group of people and then
all of a sudden towards the end
Sigourney Weaver's like you know what
I'm gonna take care of stuff and she did
tried the whole movie I was like I know
this girl I know this girl where is she
from then it dawned on me step up 3d
safe to say she's better in this movie
her character's awesome and by far the
best part of this movie and she's what
made the last half hour of this movie
incredibly great I really enjoyed the
last 30 minutes of this movie for me it
saved the entire movie because up until
then it was very straightforward very
cliched and I didn't really think
think about it was special at all and I
kept telling myself why were so many
people hyping this movie for so long and
I think that's gonna be damaging to this
film because so many people who saw it
at that first festival in 2011 made it
out to be the next Halloween
the next scream they just made it out to
be like this incredible incredible film
for me I just think it's an OK horror
film with a kind of rocky start a kind
of rocky middle and a fantastic finish
with a great musical score that's
definitely where the pluses of this
movie I'm gonna give your next of b- it
is kind of disappointing for me because
i heard so many great things about it
critics were praising it so much lots of
jump scares made through music not too
much genuine tension for the most part
the last 30 minutes of this movie are
awesome but up until then I was very
disappointed so guys if you've seen your
next or you got to see it soon let me
know what you thought of it below and as
always thanks very much for watching and
if you like this you can click right
here and get stuck mine eyes
[Music]